dans l'actualité c'était ce week-end il
y avait cette élection de Mister France
on va revenir sur cet événement qui se
déroulait du côté de Poissy c'est un
concours qui existe Jessie depuis 20 ans
et donc la finale de l'édition 2023
c'était du côté du théâtre de Poissy
alors vous étiez présent pour Radio
sensation mais vous allez faire vivre à
noter le spectateurs refaire vivre à
tv78 les spectateurs TV 78 cet événement
que soit dans les préparatifs les
répétitions et l'élection en elle-même
vous avez rien loupé effectivement 28
candidats au départ un venus représenter
chacun leur région avec bien sûr
l'Île-de-France avec Raphaël Oro
impossible de passer à côté de ce
francilien 1m89 78 kg étudiant en STAPS
à Paris Saclay il est originaire de
Dourdan et il m'a expliqué pourquoi il
souhaitait représenter justement notre
région moi je viens d'une petite
campagne dans le 91 et donc j'aimerais
la représenter ce soir pour montrer que
l'Île-de-France n'existant pas qu'à
Paris et que donc la ville de Dourdan
qui est un peu connue pour son château
midi là notamment sont un peu
représentés en Île-de-France tout
d'abord il y a Paris mais il y a pas que
Paris il y a aussi Fontainebleau
notamment avec la forêt c'est une grande
diversité l'Île-de-France et donc on va
essayer de la représenter au maximum ce
soir alors tout l'après-midi les
candidats se sont préparés dans une
ambiance plutôt détendue mais si rien
n'allait même si rien pardon a laissé
était au hasard tout a été soigneusement
répété après avec une chorégraphe
l'entrée en scène le discours ou encore
la démarche et j'imagine que plus
l'après-midi passait plus la pression
montée oui alors deux heures avant le
grand show chaque candidat est passé
entre les mains des coiffeurs et Barber
histoire de de peaufiner leurs look
ensuite tous sont allés se changer avant
que la cérémonie ne commence la pression
est montée d'un cran vous l'aurez
compris mais pas question de se laisser
aller les 28 candidats ont d'ailleurs pu
profiter des derniers conseils de Lenny
Labourel alors c'était le Mister France
2022 il a assisté à la dernière
répétition mais il était aussi là pour
conseiller et encourager les prétendants
au titre il avait le rôle un petit peu
de grand frère écouter je suis là
justement en tant que grand justement
pour aider les candidats vraiment les
motiver à leur donner des petits
conseils comme tu as pu voir justement
et vraiment bah les motiver surtout et
vraiment je suis là pour essayer de les
conseiller des quadriller un peu et
quand ils sont un peu bordelaise qui
partent un peu comme des fous vous ben
je suis là vraiment pour les remettre
d'aplomb et là cérémonie a débuté aux
alentours de 20h15 est-ce qu'il y avait
de l'ambiance au théâtre de Poissy alors
beaucoup d'ambiance beaucoup de monde
aussi environ 1200 personnes dans le
public des fans mais aussi les proches
et parfois les les familles de certains
candidats beaucoup de bruits de cris et
d'applaudissements notamment pendant
certaines épreuves d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous connaissez sur le plateau peut-être
les différentes étapes de de Mister
France
en termes de différentes étapes il y a
plusieurs étapes
de culture générale c'est ça il y a un
test de culture générale défilé on
imagine peut-être répondre à des
questions du public je sais pas alors il
y avait pas de question du public il y
avait un test de culture générale pas de
costume traditionnel malheureusement je
vous sens un petit peu un petit peu déçu
surtout qui Gabriel alors il y aura un
discours il y a eu un discours il y a
une petite chorégraphie pour l'ouverture
de la soirée un défilé en peignoir et
bien évidemment un défiler en
sous-vêtements de quoi réchauffer
l'ambiance dans la salle du Théâtre de
Poissy et pour les candidats de montrer
leur meilleur atouts l'élection Mister
France n'est pas seulement un beau
visage et un corps parfait tout de même
non alors vous aviez eu raison Gabriel
il y a eu un test de culture générale
mais on n'a pas eu les résultats plus
sérieusement chaque candidat défendait
une cause et chacun a eu l'occasion d'en
parler sur scène alors il y a eu la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire la prévention contre les
addictions et la délinquance la
délinquance pardon ou encore la lutte
contre la maltraitance animale et les
actions en faveur de environnement avant
que le jury présidé par Nathalie Marquay
Pernaut ancienne Miss France ne se
retire les candidats ont pu défiler en
costume on les voit l'image justement
les les candidats j'en profite pour
accueillir Florence Mercadier choqué qui
va nous parler de son exposition dans un
sens si on peut remettre la petite image
en plateau est-ce que vous avez
peut-être un préféré un candidat préféré
regarder on les voit alors on voit pas
forcément leur représentation
de région mais voilà plusieurs candidats
j'ai dit tout à l'heure 29 il y en avait
en réalité 28 je sais pas est-ce que
vous avez repéré un préféré non
peut-être pas un plateau
particulièrement de mon côté
votre favori moi en plus j'ai pu
échanger avec eux c'était Mister Réunion
où il y avait aussi Mister province au
Pays Basque voilà c'était mes préférés
et alors tous vos vœux n'ont
malheureusement pas été exaucé
malheureusement non ni pour Mr
Île-de-France le gagnant de la soirée
c'est Mister Corse il s'appelle Lysandre
van Wilders et devient donc Mister
France 2023 il est diplômé d'une licence
de STAPS 1m87 88 kg est assez timide
mais il devrait représenter dignement
l'île de beauté et même la France
écoutait sa réaction après son élection
pour moi l'étape la plus difficile
c'était vraiment l'étape où j'ai dû
parler devant le public parce que comme
je l'ai dit je suis quelqu'un de réservé
de base et franchement je me suis je les
avais comme ça alors moi ma cause c'est
l'environnement comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans mon discours j'ai vraiment
envie de m'engager dans cette direction
parce que c'est hyper important pour moi
j'avais pour idée de faire la prévention
moi de mon côté j'agis de manière
individuelle au quotidien je ramasse des
déchets est-ce que tout le monde peut
faire et j'encourage fortement à le
faire d'ailleurs
alors les ordres remportent donc
quelques cadeaux un des partenaires et
puis surtout ils représentera maintenant
la France lors de différents événements
médiatiques c'est le cas pour Miss
France il y a Miss France ces deux fines
et ce que là il y a aussi des dauphins
peut-être des prix supplémentaires dans
cette élection ah oui Mr France 2022
lénite à bourré la remis un prix un peu
spécial c'est l'écharpe de la sapin la
sympathie à Mr Roussillon alors c'est
juste le candidat le plus sympathique en
qualité élu par ses par ses autres
misters finalement on a eu Mister France
Languedoc qui a reçu l'écharpe du
quatrième dauphin Mister France Mister
France Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui a été
troisième dauphin Mr France
Nord-Pas-de-Calais deuxième dauphin et
bonne surprise lors de cette soirée car
ces mystères Mayotte qui a remporté
l'écharpe du premier dauphin le tout
après une présélection le vote du public
par SMS et le choix du jury et dans tout
ça vraiment rien pour notre local de
l'étape Mister Île-de-France alors non
malheureusement il y a même pas été
sélectionné dans les 12 candidats du
coup pour pour la demi-finale entre
guillemets alors je voudrais juste
préciser que chaque candidat a cette
élections ont vu des tickets de tombola
à leurs proches à leurs amis à leur
famille et même pendant plusieurs
événements et en fait donc le prix qui a
été qui a été récolté enfin le voilà
tout ce qui a été récolté pour pour ces
tickets tombola serve à soutenir
l'association l'enfant bleu donc il y a
eu plus de 3600 € qui ont été récoltés
pour pour l'association merci Jessie
merci d'avoir suivi merci pour Radio
sensation est-ce qu'il y a également
pour tv78 cette soirée on pourra
retrouver l'intégralité des interviews
et les coulisses sur les réseaux sociaux
de radio sensation d'ailleurs je crois
que les candidatures pour Mister France
2024 sont déjà ouvertes ce sont déjà
ouvertes je vais peut-être aller tenter
ma chance renseignez-vous moi je vais
pouvoir je vais peut-être aussi y
réfléchir un petit avis sur l'élection
Mister France Florence Merka des choqué
Mister France a priori égalité des sexes
c'est très mis en avant beaucoup moins
Mister France donc ça c'est bien d'en
parler mais ça s'est passé en plus dans
les Yvelines du côté du théâtre 2